[Music]
ergo one on me
well
yes Alice you are the other way
butchy tonight
[Music]
after nine years on ice solo
infiltration of the Soviet main ground
forces
should be the perfect one
normally there would be tutorial here
but we'll go ahead and skip that today
you can't have much left in him I gave
him three days tops
we fail he dies we lose our chance of
revenge but we need more Intel you just
go charging into dough and dejar you'll
be putting both your lives at risk
see what you can find out first Soviets
have other outposts not just the one you
saw Afghanistan is a big place
I expect you become quite familiar with
those binoculars as you plan your next
move how and where you make it well
that's up to you from here on out you're
on your own
you're a legend in the eyes of those who
live on the battlefield that's why you
have to handle this mission yourself
but those nine years behind you and
returned is Big Boss
that's out cause with wine
I'll be sending additional Intel by
radio
stay sharp not one of Miller's
bodyguards survived they were good all
we found on the scene were their corpses
you'll be missing it and you're his only
hope of getting him back
now go
let the legend come back to life right
now we transition seamlessly from
cutscene into gameplay everything you're
seeing here today is on PlayStation 4
running at 8 at 1080p 60 frames per
second as he heard during the cutscene
our mission here is to rescue Miller
that said we have a limited limited
amount of time today so we're gonna show
you a special version of the mission and
those prepared just for you three so
let's go ahead and start off by opening
four I enjoy looking at our mission info
and you see here the area that we need
to jump with infiltrate but you can't
just charge right into enemy territory
so we'll go ahead and Scout the area
first we'll set a marker here at
advantage point on site then we'll go
ahead and head on in and yes this is
very popular at e3 your horse will do
that so let's go ahead and move on so as
everybody knows phantom pain is an
open-world game it's roughly 300 times
the size of ground zeroes and we're just
going to show you a small glimpse of
that today so you have a day president
is gonna be like that's a wide-open
landscape a lot of places to explore a
lot of think you do as you see up ahead
it's also populated by various types of
wildlife and I have a herd of sheep up
here on the road and off to the right we
also have a human settlement wall
all right now you notice the background
music has changed it's got a little
tense that means their enemies nearby so
let's go ahead and scout out the area
and sure enough some enemies here so
we'll go ahead and mark them and proceed
Ford that said if you're on a horse like
this you're probably be spotted so let's
go ahead and use one of snakes new
abilities you can actually hang off the
side of your horse here and lower your
profile we can get up close and make the
shot
[Music]
it's one guy but his buddy did notice so
we'll use that to our advantage
see if we can sneak up behind him here
hopefully pull them up hold on now we
have them held up you can get some intel
all of them would interrogate him and
he's telling us where we can find a
container with raw materials so we'll
check that out in a minute but first
let's get these guys out of the way I
what you see on the screen right now is
the Fulton recovery system players with
a few Swampert if we're familiar with
this these guys who come back from other
basically a balloon and will join your
army and now we see here we also have a
curious visitor so maybe he wants to go
back to mother base to just go ahead and
see if we can help him out with that and
he's down we'll go ahead and attach the
Fulton and away he goes all right
look at our map here you can see the
container that I was talking about so
we'll go ahead and check that out it's
not too far off course now keep in mind
the guys we pulled and earlier we'll be
going back to mother base and you can
assign them to various units within
mother base to do tasks for you and as
for the Sheep oh I'm sure we can find
some useful all right so here's the
container and we see it as guarded we'll
be careful as we make our approach here
note that we did mark the enemy so we
can see him through obstacles such as
this wall and it said doesn't look like
he's planning on moving so let's go
ahead and lure him out the knock is back
in phantom pain but this time you can
now perform it using your prosthetic arm
which means you can do this anywhere you
do not need to be next to a wall that
said you are next to the wall you can do
some pretty cool CQC such as this
upgraded move here and peeking out from
behind cover shooting enemies is also
faster and easier than it wasn't on
zeroes all the stuff is this has been
streamlined
for a VP right these guys are all the
way and I'll see you can grab this
container
jump off here you do have to be careful
when you're folding large objects like
this because if you're actually on the
object when it goes up you'll be brought
back to mother base along with it and
you'll actually borth the mission now
that is an advanced technique to some
people when you want to use from time to
time but obviously for today's
demonstration we don't want our
Commission so we'll just keep on moving
you may have also noticed that there's a
weather report that came in on our
idroid saying there's a sandstorm
approaching so if you look at the sky
you can see it's got little gray and we
should see some stands there and up here
soon
so here we have the sandstorm stands
firm is just one example of that dynamic
weather independent pain the weather
will change and evolve throughout the
day and is unpredictable during a
sandstorm visibility is low which means
enemies can't see you but you also have
a hard time somewhere going so you have
to be careful if you traverse the Train
guys been hiding like this go ahead and
take them out now we could pull through
this guy if we wanted to but we won't
because it is in the middle of a
sandstorm and the Fulton is influenced
by weather so it's very possible that it
be blown off-course and the guy could
die so we don't want to do that that
said visibility is low but we've marked
our destination earlier so we can just
just keep on following the marker on
screen again make our way towards our
destination
and the ID is now telling us that where
there's been a clear soon and the
soldiers defaulting earlier I made it
back to mother base safely but before we
move on you'll notice that there's
something sparkling underneath this tree
just go ahead and take a look all right
so these are raw diamonds now raw
diamonds just one example of the various
raw materials you can gather from around
the map and these get sent back to
mother base and add to your GNP GNP
being the currency and offensive pain
that you can use to upgrade your base as
well as develop new items anything all
right so we've made it to our vantage
point now see off in the distance we got
the yellow marker that indicates our
target so somewhere in there we should
be able to find some information
regarding those whereabouts so let's go
ahead and use our binoculars to scope
the area out see our target here and
there's some enemies so we'll go ahead
and mark them as players who play
grounds there's no it's always good to
mark enemies before you head into enemy
territory it'll give you an advantage as
you sneak around the base
and so now we've gone ahead and mark all
the enemies that we can see that said we
don't know if there may be more lurking
behind corners inside of buildings so in
this kind of situation you can actually
call upon mother base for help hope on
our Intel unit so go ahead open up our
ID over here well you see in the
background right now is mother base all
the guys that we Fulton are being sent
back here and if we take a look at our
staff list we'll see at the bottom here
pulling you guys here they've been added
so let's go ahead and assign one of
these guys to our employee you'll also
notice that the UI is three-dimensional
and you can actually move it around like
so by moving your controller and you can
also close it by shaking the controller
like that which is pretty cool alright
so we now have the Intel coming in so
let's take a look at our map and you see
these red areas marked on the screen
please indicate anticipated enemy
locations we'll go ahead and mark these
and we'll take a look now you notice
enemies are entering these areas until
team has come through go ahead and mark
them all
okay so we went ahead and mark all the
enemies you'll note that there are quite
a few of them the base is actually
pretty well guarded at this time so well
we could try to sneak in and be very
difficult and in this kind of situation
it might actually be a better idea to
wait until their change shifts isn't
found of pain enemies build change
shifts pending on time of day and we
could do that just by sitting here
waiting for a very long time but we're
gonna use an item that can help us out
here and it's called the phantom cigar
now the Phantom cigar is an e cigar the
snake can use to help pass the time so
go ahead and use that keep in mind that
it is an e cigar so it produces no ash
no real smoke
more evidence of snakes ever being there
smoke you see on the screen right now is
actually a holida on them welcome to
smoke if you look at the sky you see
this piles are moving in real time Sun
and room across the sky as well and we
have realistic shadows being cast from
the vegetation all thanks to part of the
Fox engine the panel right here we can
see enemies moving around changing ships
depending on the time of day and if we
open up our ID we see these blue
triangles which indicate enemies who are
sleeping so depending on the time of day
people may be off their ships take a nap
and use that to advantage as you find
your infiltration group and keep in mind
you can stop this at any time so we'll
just go ahead and stop it here it is
free as you want now here we are we're
gonna head it and marked everything up
naturally you probably would want to go
in under the cover of darkness under
normal circumstances but we want to make
sure you see what's going on during
today's presentation so we'll go in
during the day and help us out we'll go
ahead and place some markers here these
will act as waypoints as we sneak around
through the base and make sure we don't
get lost on our way to the destination
all right so yeah I mean filtration all
it's set that said since we are going in
and broad daylight it's gonna be pretty
tough so once again let's go ahead and
hold on mother base for a male person
healthier and the in mother base you
actually have an R&D department that can
develop new weapons and equipment so
today we're gonna have them develop the
ultimate in stealth technology as any
true male your fan knows it is the
cardboard box so we'll go ahead and
place that order
here comes the delivery
hello did it break no this is just a
delivery box the actual box inside of
there and here it is so now we have our
stuff a customized diamond dogs
cardboard box let's head on in keep in
mind the approach we're taking today is
just one possibility it's an open world
game you can afford you can approach
targets from any direction there's just
one possibility that were showing you
for today's demonstration now that we're
in the open let's go ahead and try out
our new box now players who have played
metal giving or obviously familiar with
the cardboard box but it has been
upgraded for TPP and will show you one
of those new moves now you can actually
pop up out of the top of the box take
guys out and quickly duck back in all
without having to unequip and Requip the
box likewise you can now also use the
Fulton from the box off
in the background you got another guy
here so you sneak up alot so you can
surprise him from behind
hold them up and send them on his way
over here we see another guy who could
be a problem
now we could you the track these are
trying to take him out but we'll try
something different here we actually
have a supply unit in mother support
unit mother basically to get a supply
drops go ahead an order one
now supply drops are useful for ordering
items and ammunition but you can also
use in creative ways and we'll show an
example of that today so what we did was
he called we call the Supply Drop right
onto an enemy location and let's see
what happens so we got the guy knocked
out and that's man in the process so
let's go ahead and pick that up
right we teach the next marker now that
said the way up the head is guarded so
let's see we can take a detour through
this building here sweep around that guy
all right and it looks like we've
stumbled upon a guy who's just coming
off his shift so he's taking a nap
because of that we don't need to engage
him as long as we're quiet he's not a
threat to us so we'll go ahead and sneak
around here quietly
carefully make our way to the door base
and quick CQC to take care of that guy
and I'll be back in the open let's go
ahead and throw our box
okay and it looks like someone may have
noticed our box moving this is not good
he's obviously gonna come and suspect
this so we should probably do something
and pretend to pain you can actually do
this you can abandon the box at any time
and this is actually a very useful move
because now the enemy will go to
investigate the box while you were
escape and it'll actually serve as a
decoy as we sneak around the side of the
building here now previously we showed
you how you can Fulton people as well as
containers you can also Fulton vehicles
in the kind of pain so let's go ahead
and clean this car here from other base
that said you do need to be careful
because there may be enemies lurking
behind objects take care this guy and
survey the area to make sure the coast
is clear
okay another guy come in here
we should probably hide let's go to a
dumpster
now this dumpster is just one example of
the various objects on the stage that
you can use to hide in and you also have
upgraded CQC that you can use from
within these objects typically take eyes
out and stash them away
that our next marker keep on moving
all right that yellow mark up there on
the second floor of the building is our
destination let's make our way there
without being spotted
here keep an eye on just receive that's
good
but somebody flow right and they noticed
us let's lay low here in the ditch for a
while
all right nice headshot
and the coast looks clear so keep on
moving and we'll take the high road here
we have a better vantage point as we
proceed course marking enemies as we go
right now we need to get up to the
second floor of this building so let's
go ahead and make our entry here and the
soldiers as well as the raw diamonds we
picked up earlier and now I made it back
to mother base I think our GMP and the
vehicle as well close call look good you
can reflex mode to keep on moving
you need to get up the second floor
which looks clear so we'll go ahead and
pull from this guy and have a lot and
you should be able to find some Intel in
here that'll just another just take a
look we also have APO W here so let's
take a closer look and see who this is
and it's actually our gameplay master
Jack Ethan all someone is Don [ __ ] in
Japanese there is cool
how you feelin not too good all right so
we'll help Jack in a minute but we'll go
ahead and pick up these documents first
I drew candies in okay so we have the
intel all we know gotta do now is get
Jackie out of here and that's not
working if you look at the full tonight
on you're watching the location zero
percent right now which means we can't
use it indoors let's go ahead and carry
him outside
and now we should be okay
there goes all right so we have our
Intel and we have Jackie off to safety
all we gotta do is just get from the
base and we are done that said it's
bought it's gonna fight our way out but
don't worry even in this situation
mother days can once again provide
support so we'll go ahead and call them
up place it over to our support unit and
call in an airstrike so we'll go ahead
and set the target here and this should
help the pink things up quite nicely
also call in a helicopter so it can
escape all right now when you do is you
run and get out of here speak as you can
because obviously we don't want to be
here when the bombs start dropping or
we'll be talking unless my mother is
stealth at this point it's all about the
state
and we see a vehicle here which should
help us do that in high jacket
strikers incoming hurry here get a look
and see if we can see the explosions
that we are nice
incoming
all right now we made it safely onto
Morpho that said in the phantom pain
you're never truly safe and to escape
from enemy territory that does include
enemy airspace so we'll keep an eye open
here
see some enemy reinforcements coming in
blow but it looks like we're in the fear
less mission complete and I'll see how
we did
s Frank so a good job Jackie let's give
them a hand alright so you may think
it's over at this point but it's not we
actually have more for you coming up and
it's actually something that we prepared
special for e3 s the first time showing
this so we're gonna cut back to the game
right now and show you something
completely new it's not over yet let's
go back to the video okay so up to this
point we've talked about mother base a
lot we've been sending people back there
by hoping now we're actually going to
show you the mother base so in fact the
paint mother base the National Patient
that you can visit the mother base you
see on the screen here is actually one
that we've got really quite a bit first
start out it's just one small platform
and you slowly gather resources and
build it up and the cool thing about it
is that everyone's mother base will be
different and will be unique because you
can gather resources and customize it
building platforms however you want
decide how you want spend your resources
so really building it up and showing off
your friends is one of the big pool and
new things well time to paint alright so
right now this big structure you see
here is the main platform make our coach
we can now actually disembark from the
helicopter
and we'll give you a customized to our
mother base all right so you see your
men coming up and saluting you obviously
you are their commander you're a big
boss these are men your Diamond Dogs
take a moment to you look at the base
here so you can get a sense of the scale
of it all pretty huge and just remember
that you the player will be creating all
this moving on all right
and we see our friends the Sheep and
Jackie have made it back to mother base
safely they seem to be getting along
nicely so as you can see all the
personnel we puts in from the field so
you come back to mother base speed here
the inner fortune of mother base and you
get some gunfire now and if you look
over to a left you can see it it's
actually a shooting range so I while
you're out doing your missions your men
may be off on combat missions of their
own or they may be here practicing their
skills so you can also practice with
them if you like you can engage the
sequence if you see with them spar try
to see your skills and also raise their
school of us as well but we won't do
that today we'll go ahead and proceed up
the stairs here just to give you a
better view of the base
and you see up here an anti-aircraft gun
this is one example of artillery that
you can actually Fulton from the field
and bring back to mother base equipment
like this can be picked up in your
mission and bought back here to serve as
a part of your defenses
likewise you see in the distance here
the Fulton continually picked up to your
Fulton has made it back to another base
and the vehicles are there so all of
these things in Fulton whether it be
people vehicles or controller resources
come back to mother base and resources
to contribute to GMT which you can spent
expand your base and building platforms
and we see an example of this right here
so that's the platform under
construction it'll be available in the
future you can also spend resources on
upgrading security and this UAV is one
example of that you think these guys
buzzing around and these guys help to
keep your base safe while you're out in
your missions all right and we see a
familiar face here it's all [ __ ] just
hanging out saying hi so unique
characters like all slot will also be
around the base and you can actually
interact with in this wall right now you
notice it's started to rain once again
this is an example of the dynamic
weather that we've had in terms of pain
which exists not only during your
missions but also here at motivates
all right and now they're shooting
something or not it sounds like an alarm
take a look
okay the basin should be I'll alert and
then I have you combat statements let's
go ahead and do the same
any more holes incoming sis go ahead and
want to be with them note also that
Jackie is taking a lot of shortcuts here
obviously this is a mother base and
every player will know their base inside
and out shortest way is from 2809 to eat
so here we are now back on the main
platform
all right hop on morto and head into
battle so as you can tell from the alert
your base independent pain can be
attacked which means that all the
relationships you make within your
mission and online will come back and
affect you here some other basis not
just provide support to your mission but
all of the things that you do or
relationship or in your mission come
back and like you here by the base and
it's all one big endless cycle
and that concludes our e3 presentation
thank you for watching
[Music]